how does it feel to be out here in
public in front of everybody for the
first time weird we are beyond excited
to finally be out yes Colton and his
leading lady Cassie opening up to et
just hours after the season finale of
The Bachelor that's been the scariest
part I wish you this whole time it's not
no one working event and Cassie
addressed to the haters who doubt her
love for Colton i journal was like the
entire time and i went back and read my
journals and even in denver I was like
journaling to myself saying I'm not sure
though do i and so I think the whole
time I was just really unsure of how I
felt and I didn't know if I could trust
my feelings really but pretty soon after
the cameras in a way is when I realized
okay this is real I really do love him
and now we've been happy and
when
well he reacted
you know there were so many it was so
overwhelming that entire ending to that
whole show and with Colton I did love
him and I cared about him so much I
didn't want to leave him um I didn't
necessarily know that I had had enough
time to make a lifelong commitment to
him in the time allotted sitting there
on that couch in Portugal we had two
weeks until an engagement and I was like
I'm not there yet and I couldn't be sure
if I could get there and so I wanted him
to have an engagement which is but he
had been saying he came there for so
that's why I left not because I didn't
love didn't care about it but I do it
bugs me that people say that I don't I
don't know what I'm ready for
I feel good right now
yeah yeah Oh even emit as The Bachelor I
came into it with the assumption because
you were the bachelor it ends in an
engagement and you know while that works
for some people and while that's been
the case for the last few years it
wasn't what was best for our
relationship and I realized in that
moment I didn't want to lose Cassie and
I would do whatever it took
forget the show at that time I was
fighting for somebody who I loved I was
fighting for a relationship that I
wanted to last forever are you planning
on getting engaged
it's definitely something we've talked
about Cassie also took on those rumors
that she wanted to be the next
Bachelorette the bachelorette
conversation did happen on the bus from
the airport in Singapore to the hotel it
was a conversation between Kayla and I
on the bus and she was like if I'm with
Colton and I want you to be back so I
was like well fine with Colton I want
you to be Bachelorette I think that's
completely normal and completely fine
but I think it was like a game of
telephone that just kind of got twisted
and I think it turned into drama
way over play yeah brought it along and
taking too far yeah and it's sucks
because like my intentions were so pure
the whole time on Tuesday's finale Chris
Harrison announced Hanna B is the next
Bachelorette you are the Bachelorette so
what do Cassie and Colton think of the
choice I think she's going to make for a
very interesting and dynamic season and
she's so deserving Bob love she's
somebody who stayed true to herself
throughout the whole entire filming
process yeah I'm excited to watch her
season of course I wish her the best
yes
[Music]
[Applause]